Female: Into the globe, let's now go
to California where Sal Khan is using
YouTube in a way that might
just blow up the classroom.
Sal: We're trying to educate the world.
Female: Tutoring millions online.
Sal: That's what's cool about an equation.
You can always check to see
if you got the right answer.
Right now we're getting
2 to 300,000 views a day.
We claim to be the largest
university in the world.
Female: More than 2400
lessons and counting on
everything from basic addition.
Sal: 8 + 1 = 9
Female: To quadratic formulas.
Sal: Negative 1 times 2 is -2.
Female: Photosynthesis.
Sal: It needs carbon dioxide.
Female: To U.S. history.
Sal: We've had enough
of you, Great Britain.
We are now declaring ourselves
as an independent country.
Female: Any subject just search and click,
all viewed more than 76 million times.
Sal: They can pause, repeat,
rewind without feeling like
they're wasting my time,
without feeling embarrassed
because maybe they weren't
paying attention the first time
or maybe they forgot something
from last year or last week and now
it's in a destressed environment.
Female: It's a long way
from where it all began.
Sal: My friend said, "Hey why don't you
put some of your lectures on YouTube?"
I said, "No, that's for dogs
on skateboards. That's not
for serious mathematics."
Female: And yet that was the
light bulb moment for you.
Sal: I gave it a shot.
Female: It's now called Khan Academy.
Bill Gates: What Sal
Khan has done is amazing.
Female: He's been called Bill Gates'
favorite teacher because Gates' own sons
were logging on to Khan's lessons.
Bill Gates: I see Sal Khan as a
pioneer. It's the start of a revolution.
Female: The Gates Foundation
gave him 1.5 million dollars.
Google tossed in 2 million. Enough
to hire a small staff and translate
his lessons into ten languages.
Sal: If it was just a constant,
we would be able to use the
[unintelligible] but we can't do that.
Female: Sal is the only instructor
and he knows what he's talking about.
The MIT and Harvard grad got three
degrees simultaneously in math,
electrical engineering
and computer science.
But Sal has a dirty little secret.
Sal Khan, one of the best teachers
in the world, hated school?
It didn't register with me. I would
go to class. Half the time I was
bored. Half the time I was lost.
I had trouble paying
attention for 60 minutes.
Female: Which may be why Sal
is an education revolutionary.
Sal: Everything I have listed is true
of both 401Ks and traditional IRAs.
Female: You could make a lot
of money off of your brain, but
you're giving it away for free.
Sal: Hopefully on my death
bed, and hopefully that's
many decades in the future.
Female: A hundred years from now.
Sal: A hundred years from
now I'll be able to say,
"There's a billion kids who learned from
those lectures, or five million kids."
Female: We have a little surprise for you.
We connected Sal with just
one of his millions of fans.
Jasper is a medical
student in the Netherlands.
Male: Oh, yeah.
Female: Who has spent a lot of time
with you. You just don't know it.
Male: I watched some
videos and they were great.
They really helped to
understand what I had to do.
Sal: That's awesome, see? I could
sleep and help teach people the
Kreb's cycle. It's exciting.
One person can produce something on
their own without any extra resources
almost as a hobby and you
can reach millions of people.
Female: It's a place of big and
small. Whether you're storm chasing,
[unintelligible] revolution,
or just trying to learn
biology, it's a world connected.